I was recently standing in line this
very crowded coffee shop and there was
this young mother in line in front of me
and she had two little girls I'd say
aged like three and five and little
girls kept running off with a crowd and
disappearing and coming back and then
running off and coming back and finally
they were ran off and only one came back
and the mom went down to the one that
came back she's like hey Sydney where'd
your sister Brooklyn go Sydney where's
Brooklyn Sydney what happened to your
sister Brooklyn Sydney where's Brooklyn
it took every ounce of restraint I have
in my body not to just be like where
Brooklyn at where Brooklyn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there she is I thank God don't name
your children after cities there'll be
one of two things a stripper or a member
of a posse that's it
that one's Brooklyn this one we call kid
Montana and that fellow we just referred
to as the Comanche don't make eye
contact with the Comanche Wendy's
recently got rid of their slogan and I
miss it because I loved it
their slogan was it's way better than
fast food it's Wendy's really that's
like saying it's way better than cancer
it's testicular cancer and applying that
one Wendy's I am however a big fan of
UPS's slogan ups the slogan is what can
Brown do for you every time I hear that
I just want to yell out sue the Board of
Education
[Applause]
Thank You book readers Thank You book
readers when I was in second grade some
mornings we'd go into the school and the
classroom would be arranged like an
airplane to long rows of chairs and then
we'd sit in those chairs and using the
powers of our very fertile second grade
imaginations we pretend to fly to
countries all over the world and learn
about him yeah the other day I left
twelve dollars on a six dollar food
purchase because I messed up calculating
a 20% tip sometimes you just need to go
to school and do math I can tell you 90%
of the animals that live on the
Serengeti if the little hand on the
clock goes to four or five I don't know
what's happening 4:30 meeting that's
awesome I'll be there at 3:00 or 6:00
thanks Montessori I don't know how to do
anything I don't know how to do things I
do know there's two types of energy
however potential and connecticut that
much I know
connecticut energy the energy to be very
liberal but ultimately really boring
when i was in fifth grade my best friend
i'd go to the mall and we go to spa row
and we get pepperoni pizza and we'd eat
the pepperoni off the pizza while we're
in line and then we'd only pay for
cheese oh we thought we were geniuses
and then in high school that same exact
friend and I would see a bunch of little
items from a sporting goods store and
then we returned them to eat enough
store credit saved up to get north face
coats like puffy and mace we thought we
were geniuses and then in college that
same exact friend got expelled for
plagiarizing a paper and then he knocked
up his 19 year old girlfriend and I
realized only I was a genius
[Applause]
my mom is from the south so I grew up
half racist I kid because I love
southerners have cool sayings that the
rest of the country does not use and we
should because they're amazing I'll give
you an example I was going for a hike
with my grandma outside of Richmond in
Virginia and it was sunny outside but it
started to rain a little bit and without
any provocation on my part my grandma
just blurts out she goes hey you know
what they say when it's sunny outside
it's rainin means it devil's beating his
wife where does that come from
grandma couped was in about two hours
after that we found ourselves at the
Cracker Barrel because that's what you
do yeah and my grandma made us thank
Jesus for biscuits and free refills and
I realized my grandma doesn't have the
firmest grasp on theology I told that
joke at a show one time and this hick in
the back he yells out he goes Richmond
Virginia
I need this South two attire responded
well it was the capital of the
Confederacy to which he responded gay he
repealed the logic sir
[Applause]
sigh very much appreciated